now let's share this prototype with
someone there are three ways to do this
first you can select the share link
button this allows you to generate a
unique URL that anyone can view your
project screens can be viewed on a
desktop or mobile device anyone with
this link can view interact with and
comment on your screens you can email it
SMS embed it or even downloaded for
offline viewing simply copy and paste
this URL and send it to your participant
second you can add someone to your
project as a collaborator adding a
collaborator to your project effectively
gives them full edit access this enables
them to view interact with comment on
the screens edit and add and remove
screens as well as edit add or remove
hotspots to do this simply click on the
plus sign in the upper right of your
project home view adding a collaborator
will give that person full access to
your project third you can start an
instant live share event a live share
meeting enables you to have a real-time
collaborative discussion with anyone
with internet access participants of
your meeting can draw add comments and
view your project in a one-time event
you can have unlimited participants in
your meeting and you don't need to book
your meetings in advance plus you can
have as many live here meetings as you
need simply copy and paste this link and
send it to anybody you want to
participate in your meeting you can turn
on a VoIP call here where people can
join a VoIP or you can have them dial in
to this phone number for private
conference line in the bottom left
you'll see that there's a group chat
window participants can turn on the
drawing tool where you can draw over
your designs or you can turn on a white
boarding option any of your designs can
be saved to a snaps folder or email to
all of your participants on the fly once
you're done with your meeting simply hit
end